do you know what would happen if DNA
testing was mandatory if they tested all
women
Calamity my sister told me the other day
this should be standard my sister told
me the last time that's why they won't
do it it should be a standard thing at
the hospital that's why they won't do it
to me it just makes sense
DNA test I'm doing it I'm doing a
documentary on the court system here in
the UK and I um I was interviewing this
guy he he works for it's called fathers
for justice and they help men get
custody of their kids and one thing I
found out is in the UK I mean you were
actually given a free free Council which
is a lawyer basically if you accuse your
husband of abuse and what the women can
do is they can accuse the guy of abuse
and
um file a restraining order against him
even if he did nothing and if he breaks
that he actually goes to jail and it can
take one to two years to even get the
kid back so he could have a newborn and
not see the kid for two years over a
false allegation